uh this is just an unbelievable
instance of spin when it comes to
january 6. so
we've talked a lot about this hearing
that took place yesterday we started
at the beginning of the show with the
statements made by biden administration
officials about the greatest domestic
terror threat in the united states
which merrick garland and others believe
is white supremacist
domestic terror and i believe the
numbers confirm that that's the case
we also learned just in the last segment
because of donald trump's former
acting uh secretary of defense that
more than three hours went by between
when the riots started
and when there was finally an
authorization given for the national
guard to clear the capitol
we then saw a questioning from
republican congressman jody heiss
where he argued that the real
victims on january 6th it wasn't the
american people
it wasn't uh the police in washington dc
the real victims on january 6 says jody
heiss
were trumpists who were there in support
of donald trump
i know republican congressman jody heiss
is not exactly a brilliant guy
and uh this is the case he tried to make
during yesterday's hearings
you really have to be capable of some
incredible
revisionist history and departures from
logic
to even try to claim this but jody heist
tries
i'm going to play some of the lead up
here in this video
and then look at how he tries to portray
the trump
rioters as the real victims between 110
and 115 president trump ends his speech
and uh tells attendees to peacefully and
patriotically
make their voices heard at the capitol
about 150
the capital is breached now in this
timeline it would have been about two
o'clock before the earliest
uh attendees of trump's speech could
have arrived
at the capitol so the capital is
attacked
at the uh right shortly after the
president begins his speech
it's breached before individuals could
have gotten there
where is the the real narrative
in all of that another narrative i want
to bring up
is that the the the media claims that
the tragic death of
officer brian siegnik was a result of
pro-trump
mobs bashing his skull with the fire
extinguisher
which we all know now did not happen
officer cigna
uh his autopsy revealed that he suffered
no blunt
trauma in fact his mother has since come
out saying he died
of a stroke uh in fact it was trump
supporters who
lost their lives that day uh not trump
supporters who were taking the lives of
others
uh you go down the list here ashley
babbitt was shot and killed by a capitol
police officer
kevin greeson suffered a heart attack
uh roseanne boylan reportedly
was crushed by rioters and benjamin
phillips
died of a stroke so the narrative needs
to be cleared up
the truth matters the people he's naming
that died
died because they chose to be there
in direct violation of the law i don't
think
any death is to be celebrated here
people who have been watching the show
know that that's always been my
perspective
but look at the people that he's naming
he names ashley babbitt who was shot by
police well that's true
uh babbitt was one of the many military
service members who went to the riots
against the law
trespassing police officers have been
cleared of wrongdoing in her death
she was shot while trying to breach
doors within the capitol she was already
trespassing
she has already broken the law merely by
being in there she was trying to breach
further doors in the capitol and the
officer has been cleared
because he believed he was acting in
self-defense in the defense of members
of congress that he was sworn to protect
in any other scenario these
right-wingers would be saying that was a
justifiable police shooting
in this case they're saying the
trumpists were the victims here
uh he mentions kevin greeson kevin
greeson suffered a heart attack that's
true
uh kevin griesen was there suffered a
heart attack
reportedly after tasing himself while
allegedly trying to steal a painting
from the capitol he shouldn't even have
been there he was committing a crime by
being there
he got his hands on a taser he tasted
himself and subsequently had a heart
attack that's not
a trump supporter being a victim that's
a criminal
for whom their criminal acts went wrong
and we're not celebrating the death
but to say that that proves that the
trumpists are victims
not a very accurate statement to make um
jody heiss mentioned roseanne boyland
roseanne boyland was crushed by rioters
that is completely true she was crushed
by a stampede of trumpists of which she
was apart
as they were all breaking into the
capital it it it's sad
but why was she there she was there
breaking the law along with these other
trumpets who trampled her
it's horrible but that's what happened
uh and then lastly jody heiss mentions
benjamin phillips benjamin phillips
died of a stroke he says that's true he
was there breaking the law as well he
wasn't killed by antifa
he wasn't killed by police and to frame
trumpists as
victims who were minding their own
business
just looking at the capital and then
were killed
either by police or by antifa or left
wingers
to frame them that way rather than as
the perpetrators that they are
of a seditious attempt to overturn the
election is just pathetic
but jody heiss is exactly the type of
guy who would try it i'm not going to
give you his full
kind of greatest hits you can go back in
our
archives and find some of the horrible
things that jody heist has said over the
last decade
but it's a degree of spin that should
really make anybody dizzy it's a sort of
war is
peace freedom is slavery like it's that
type
of misinformation these were not invited
guests
who were just looking at a painting at
the capitol
and then they were run over by a mob
they were trespassing
as part of that mob and i'm trying to
remember the line
that conservatives often use after
police shootings at least
as it refers to ashley babbitt and they
say stuff like you know if they just
followed the law
and orders from police no one would
nobody would have gotten shot hurt or
killed or whatever the case may be
that it applies to ashley babud i'm not
glad she died
but this is the the the logic that they
give us
whenever there's a police shooting that
we look at and we say that seems insane
that seems like the police did something
wrong they just
they they were breaking the law already
they were criminals they weren't
listening to what police were saying
and also by the way the the version of
events that jody heiss
is kind of trying to present here um
it's almost like he doesn't realize
there's video of the entire thing
we we saw how it all went down uh and it
makes it even more pathetic but he
doesn't care and this guy really is one
of the most pathetic members of congress
out there just check out
go to my youtube channel just go to
youtube and type jody heist david pakman
and you'll see his long track record of
absurdity if you are
anything like me you probably aren't
thrilled with the idea of going into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video